hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast and I'm just checking in on you
um once again we have a guest this is
like we have guests all through February
um how do I intro this son of a [__]
this guy I have known for like 30 coming
up on 31 years
he literally the first time I ever did
stand up it was a comedy competition
find Boston's funniest college students
it was a competition they needed judges
this guy was one of the judges he
literally saw the first time I went on
stage and uh amazing comedian and he has
a new book out called billionaire
Boogeyman which I've been reading it's a
[__] page Turtle please welcome the
one and only Todd pocket dude Todd
Parker what's going on man how you doing
I'm good good to see you how come let's
you know let's just [__] address it
all right right out of the gate here we
go what was it about my set on March 2nd
1992 that just [__] made you not pick
me
and you picked somebody else what was it
what did you know it was 92 puppets were
not in at that time
I thought you know what I it wasn't even
a good puppet it's like made out of
paper cups and [__] and I'm like yeah
come on I didn't have that I did have a
dental mask though for what I had
technically a prop act and you know
what's funny what was you were the guy
that made me realize that out that
because back then dude how rigid were
the were the um
did the lines back then like you
couldn't [__] do anything it was so
weird like it started up like Milton
Berle 40 years earlier isn't like a
[__] dress on TV you know totally in
drag anything for a laugh and by the
time 1992 it literally became you know
if you moved around too much you were a
hack it was like dude you should just be
able to stand there without even moving
and just say your jokes and [__] kill
so I I had a uh I worked in a dental
office with my dad
my dad and um I had like those this this
thing when you were drilling people's
teeth all this [__] would come out of
their mouth it was [__] disgusting
and the nerve people have to hate the
dentist the way they don't even take
care of their teeth then you come in and
you you fix them and they're like oh
they they blame you for the pain right
so
it was a [__] like a tennis visor and
it was all plastic and had this clear
plastic like a welding mask and that was
my closing bit I would be like you know
talk about working at dental office I
mean my job's so [__] up I'd be like I
have to wear this and I would put it on
and the crowd would go nuts of course
and then I had no joke and then I would
have it on and I would go good night
everybody
he had a line about uh people not taking
care you think one Tic Tac in the lobby
is going to cover up six months of
regret no no uh no that wasn't the mass
joke the Masters I just put it on that
was uh I'll give you guys a hint yeah
what was it uh
20 years neglect is not cured by a Tic
Tac in the waiting room that's right
that's what I said I said you think you
got it bad you know you don't Pusheen
you have any idea what that smells like
let me tell you something he goes 20
years of neglect is not cured by a Tic
Tac in the waiting room because that
they all be doing sitting there chewing
and putting these [__] breath though
these [__] garbage mouth people I
haven't seen you about it though dude I
had another joke on my act this guy came
in the office and he said uh
he said doc you know I keep getting
these cavities I don't know I mean I
brush my teeth almost every day and then
my line in my Act was oh yeah do you
wipe your ass almost every time you take
a [__]
and I was working totally clean and then
I didn't know anything oh look at this
wholesome Ron Howard looking guy and
then I would do you wipe your ass almost
every time you take a [__] good night
everybody I don't always do that so
anyway I [__] had that goddamn mask
and you were the guy and we were
upstairs at the Kowloon
and I sat down because I remember I had
a little duffel bag I would bring it up
on it was so [__] bad dude so
embarrassing so I literally said to you
like
you're like hey dude how's it going you
know [__] Todd Parker hey dude how's
it going it sounds just like me and I
was like uh
I was like yeah man it's going good you
know I was like you know I kind of uh
kind of stopped doing that Dental mess
thing you know I was kind of thinking
like you know it's kind of like I'm so
not funny that I have to bring stuff on
stage to make me funny and you just went
yeah and when you said that dude like
literally my heart sunk I'm like oh my
God everybody thinks I'm a [__] hack
oh what a dick I'm sorry my career is
over you know what I did I had I had
props at the beginning too you know I
did I had two props when I first started
out the first thing my first few times I
at the time all the rage in the 80s were
guys driving irocs right you know
honking at girls that was every so I'm
such a great example yeah but such a
great car I had a I had a bike horn that
I had under my shirt and you couldn't
see it I was way skinny back then and
you just couldn't see it so I would do
an impression of these Italian guys who
drive irocs like how do they honk it
girls when they don't have the car like
what are they in the mall and I go like
that and it always got to laugh yes but
I think like maybe Tony V was one of the
early guys who went um like I did to you
like hmm yeah so I was like oh props are
bad what what about the night you forgot
the horn and you're like oh [__] I can't
I can't do the joke and then you're just
like and I gotta cover this time and I
don't have enough I need the not having
an IROC horn in my pants joke Tara 30 of
my five minutes yeah it was terrorists
so we all we both the two of us started
uh you start a couple year when did you
start 87 88 88 so I started in 92. so
you were a grizzled vet to me guys guys
been doing it four years by the time uh
I started and that that was back when
Nick's comedy stuff was just the [__]
place to be and I was talking about that
earlier it was like this great sort of
also weird time in Boston where like the
the Theater District the combat zone
which is where all the hookers and pimps
and drug addicts and all that [__] were
and then Chinatown all sort of like
overlapped each other and you walked out
and you had no idea what you were gonna
run into it's like I'm gonna get some
comedy I see a good show am I gonna get
a hooker am I gonna get stabbed am I
gonna get some great Chinese food right
um Yeah Dominic's was like the bar in
Star Wars everything was in there there
were cops there were hookers there were
bikers yeah and it was sort of like this
Switzerland where the hookers could come
in
yeah chill everybody knew who everybody
was right and then the comics noxy rest
his soul everybody else they would be in
that corner and that was like a big deal
for me like not only because you know
when you first a new comic you would
walk in the front door yeah and it was
that big guy sitting there I know he's
not here anymore that was Dominic that
was Dominic that was Dominic yeah dude
that guy looked like Porky from [__]
the movie Porky's he did and he was one
of those guys who sat with his [__]
legs like this the fat was the shirt the
fat was the pants and then these two
little skinny legs and he used to sit
there and he had like that cane oh then
I better get in there and when you were
a young comic you would walk in the
front door but when you started to get I
remember the first time I walked over
there knoxy was just like hey you know
good set tonight buddy
damage with us and I walked with him and
somebody else said they were all like
six foot something those original
comedies yeah big guys and they walked
through the back door I was like oh my
God I'm going through the back door and
you walk in and I was like clearly just
[__] all of of what you just
mentioned and then all of the customers
in future arrests all the Johns yeah
like everybody was just like all right
let me take a break before I get another
[__] right yeah and it was always
some couple who came in there by
accident you know like the people who
had theater tickets right who walked
across the street from the show and they
walk in and they're surrounded all of a
sudden by larapucci and bikers and
hookers and cops and everybody's just
laughing and loud and they're like uh
look could we get a uh you know a a
screwdriver or whatever yeah coming out
of like the Wang which kind of brings me
to this book here what a Segway wow what
a segue uh this is his new book uh
billionaire Boogeyman which has
everything that oh let me there you go
everything that I love in it it's got
the Illuminati it's got conspiracy
theory it's got [__] uh
um
um Bilderberg Group type of stuff all
the conspiracies all jammed with this
book and
where I am in the book it takes place
right seems like down there Warrenton
Street Stewart Street all of that [__]
right down there Nick's comedy stuff so
um what uh
since I've known you you've never been a
novelist dude at what point did you uh
sit down because I know you've done
stand up you've painted
yeah yeah you like you like this sort of
low-key Triple Threat here now all of a
sudden you wrote a book and I'm sitting
there going like oh my God Todd Parker
he writes that he can read that [__]
jerk off from the cow [__] kid can
read from Revere really I started
reading it on on the plane I'm like this
it [__] destroyed the flight I just I
killed it was great I appreciate it
actually it's an actual I hate how you
just said thanks because it squeaked it
bugged me it did yeah it bugged me too
as soon as it came out I'm like he's
gonna he's gonna jump on that it makes
me not one of them he's not gonna let
that go I'm not gonna promote your book
okay you know what it was it was the
happiness there was joy in it you can't
stand other people no as comedians our
rule is we have to we have to lay I I
gotta kill that right now what was it
about the guy that you didn't vote for
that night 30 years ago you know what I
wish liking the book made you so excited
because you it was a legitimate comment
because you've known for years I was
like one of these days you've been
grudging on me for 31 years I wish I
could go back in time and I tell people
the story whenever anybody asks like hey
you know Bill Burr like when it comes
out I'm a Boston comic I'm like yeah as
a matter of fact and I tell them and
they're like it's not what you say yeah
I know that [__] hat that son of a
[__] no gentle mask on stage no I
I have to navigate carefully when I talk
about you why because it goes into like
so uh wait he used to open for you
really yeah well then okay so you're
here at Chuck Chucks and he's way up
there how did that happen so I want to
avoid all that you know how that happens
because this business isn't fair oh stop
it
random it's random come on save that
listen first of all you know I'm not
nice
that's not true I you've got the image
but I know Underneath It All you're a
caring sensitive guy it comes out I know
if you don't want people to know that
[__] you too you want everybody to know
Bill Burr [__] you guys you [__] [__]
but everybody knows you're really nice
everybody who knows you knows that dude
I got mad at a hangar yesterday
what did the hanger do it broke nope I
just took a shirt off it and it [__]
exploded and it just it just set me off
with this like like how much [__]
money do you have to make right and you
know they sit there going like okay they
can take the shirt off like 3.7 times
and then it's going to explode what kind
of hanger was it because I'm very
particular about my hangers I like the
plastic ones with a metal top that turns
exactly no I no I like the uh the ones
that have like the fake velor oh I hate
those on those yeah that top the top
comes right off the velor one like
sticks to my t-shirts I don't like I
don't like that feeling when you go to
pull the T-shirt off that velor that
bugs me that like yeah no seriously I'm
not [__] around right you know what I
like I don't like the [__] hangers
from the dry cleaner I take those back
yeah well who's those are the like the
ghetto gangers you know what they're
great hangers but it's also like I I you
know I am into the environment you know
a little bit you know a little bit tell
by the way I dress a little bit a little
bit a little bit I like it you know I'm
not gonna you know I'm saying I'm trying
to you know
try to drink out of metal I dropped this
thing so many times look at this thing
it's like [__] tipping over here is
that supposed to be flat it's supposed
to be flat but I keep dropping it in the
parking lot and in my driveway so if you
look at the bottom there
oh [__] just poured water on there we go
I got a good joke for that
looks like the back of some fat chick's
thighs ouch um
or to be fair yeah the side where my man
tits are
um anyway I have a good Dominic story I
don't know if you know this okay what do
you got did you ever go to karaoke night
at Dominick's
I don't remember which night it was
maybe it was Tuesday I'm not sure and I
saw Dane Cook Crush uh that Queen song
[__] killed it and I remember going
like there's no [__] way this kid's
not gonna make it right because he was
already killing on stage go ahead I used
to do um dream on badly like I can't
sing I know I can't sing but uh I was so
bad at it that the crowd would like it
and it would be jammed in it would be
jam-packed and one time there were all
these bikers there was a line of 20
motorcycles out front and they were all
in surrounding the stage right remember
they had that like brass railing dude
you don't [__] with Aerosmith with those
bikers in Boston I was having fun I'm 22
years old having a blast
so do you remember the brass railing
that went around there was like a yes so
I'm doing dream on badly and the crowd
was with me but these bikers like I said
they one guy was just wasn't having it
and he climbs up over the railing and he
gets down in front of me on all fours
and he starts going like he's like hell
he's he's covered in leather and studs
and and I was so young and so stupid
that I just thought he wants to [__]
with me I'll [__] with him so I got down
behind him and I grabbed his hips and I
started driving oh my God I swear to God
and he goes what the [__] and he and he
goes to get up but I'm clamped on I do
not let go and he's like trying to get
away and how hard of his friends
laughing they're dying they're dying and
screaming and standing up and he goes
over he goes over to the Brass railing
and he's climbing it up like Apollo
Creed at the end of like Rocky 2 and
he's like oh and he keeps going down and
I am not letting go and I'm just going
bark bark bark like that and his friends
go nuts and then finally you know we
wrap up he gets away and I could not pay
for a beer whenever those bikers were
there afterwards I was like a guy are
you [__] kidding me loved it what
about the guy you did it to was he
laughing he kept his distance
he was not you kind of assaulted him oh
little bit
through first blood not me he Crawley
dude right he didn't let go no I did I
had the death grip on him I was not
letting go he was like walking he's
walking around the back of the Bronco
luckily he was like not a huge guy he
was like one of the skinnier ones you
know because I was Tiny dude is there
anything worse than when you think
you're gonna be the the guy joking and
you've become the [__] joke like uh
I'm gonna be the I'm going to be the cut
up I'm gonna be the guy with the
lampshade on my head yeah and next to
you know simulated ass rape that's how
it goes a tail is all this time get for
dominance that's just another Tuesday
I know dude that was such a what a
[__] slice of pizza was like a double
slice of pizza you know what's funny
Dave Portnoy said something very
profound about pizza uh the guy from
Barstool Sports if you don't know where
he is I know you guys you know I don't I
know you got kids you got kids no I mean
Ford aspect you know I have no idea
Sports in it right I have no clue what
you're talking about
um he was saying a giant slice of pizza
is never good was basically you know
it's like that's like you hammered you
know what I mean it's just like they're
trying to make it up with like the
portion Dominics was the only place in
Boston I ever got a double slice that
was the only thing that ever broke that
rule because I remember when he said
that he does these Pizza reviews
and when he said that I forget where I
was I just went yes yeah that is that is
100 [__] anytime there's a giant
slice I got one in Philly people
somebody told me to go there there's
this giant slice of pizza Dude that
[__] sucked [__] sucked and then
you ate all those calories it's the
worst yeah the Dominic slice was great
it had the perfect amount of Grease like
if you held it the grease would drip and
that's how I judge a good slice of pizza
I like Grease I do not So Much Anymore
let me ask you how the [__] do you grow
up in Boston
and you don't and you're not into sports
did you hate your dad was he in sports
and this is your way for my family my
dad and my brother huge Sports Nuts but
I just never got it I mean football
baseball it's a bunch of guys and tights
running around in the grass I don't what
if you can't simulate ass raping them
you have no interest
I just said it just doesn't appear to me
I just
conversations with my
what am I trying to get me into it you
know like oh there's a really important
game watch this I need like something
would happen somebody would jump and I
go well the Six Million Dollar Man can
jump like that and he'd be like the Six
Million Dollar man's not real and I'm
like well so but what's going on are you
like those sci-fi on them that's like
the double heartbreak you broke his
heart I did break his heart yeah I did
now let me ask you this was there
anything like when your kids
were coming up
um is there any because I've already
started to experience this well my kids
tell me that sports are boring like Dad
you always watch sports they're boring
because they're young they don't get it
uh my son likes car racing because he
loves the movie Cars so if he actually
sees real cars for two laps he'll be
like Dada room room he'll do that and
then he's just like uh I'm bored with
this [__] and he wants to watch garbage
trucks pick up trash so is it was it
anything and
how did you handle it if they did
um it's heartbreaking you know I wish
that they were more into comic books and
they're not and but I get accepted I
gotta take it but luckily both my kids
are huge horror movie fans so that's
cool yeah that's great because I started
them out real young
like probably I was a bad parent I
shouldn't have let them see the things
that they've seen but you know living in
like movies early on they were watching
things like
The Exorcist and the ring and the Ring
The Ring yeah oh dude I got a story
about that one tell me I was in [__]
Peoria Illinois
in an unknown Pete home still married
Pete Holmes if you ever saw his his uh
show uh crashing I love Pete homes he's
funny he's [__] hilarious he was
still married
and uh he was opening for me at this
place Brewsters I want to say and during
to kill a day we went to go see a movie
and we went to the matinee of the ring
and we walked into this dumpy theater
and we were literally the only two
people and that movie Scared the I I
can't handle like I take the ride dude
like they scared the [__] out of me I
[__] hate horror movies oh my God
they scared the [__] out of me so I
[__] get back to my room
and right when I get back to my room
this [__] [__] he called my room
and was it one of those you know Peoria
was an old school phone and it had that
perfect ring to do my [__] heart just
went down to my stomach and I picked up
and he goes seven days I'm like [__]
[__]
oh look who it is everybody it's Helix
that great heavy metal band from the 80s
Helix everybody it's Helix sleep Helix
sleep is a premium mattress brand that
provides tailored mattress mattresses
based on your unique sleep preferences
with Helix lineups include 14 unique
mattresses including a collection of
luxury models a mattress for Big and
Tall sleepers and even a mattress made
just for kids ages three to twelve you
know what I wish Andre the Giant was
still alive and he could order a
mattress from these guys and you would
see how great they are at their job so
how will you know which
mattress so it's a heavy metal name for
a band mattress works best for you and
your body take the Helix sleep quiz and
find your perfect mattress in under two
minutes
knows that there's no better way to test
out a mattress than by sleeping on it in
your own home that's why they offer a
100 night trial in a 10 to 15 year
warranty to try out your new Helix
mattress everyone is unique everyone's
special and they don't want to fill out
job applications I just want to click a
button and everyone sleeps differently
that's why Helix has several different
mattress models to choose from each
designed for specific sleep positions
and pref and field preferences if your
spine needs some extra TLC they got you
every Helix mattress has a hybrid design
combined combining individually wrapped
steel coils in the base with premium
foam layers on top it's the perfect
combination of comfort and support plus
headaches coming to the Worcester
Centrum live Alex opening for Bon Jovi
Helix mattresses are American made
and come with a 10 to 15 year warranty
depending on the model don't want to
take my word for it Helix has been
awarded the number one mattress pick by
GQ and wired Magnus dude we just went
there for Helix you know I [__] left
when Bon Jovi came out that's a [__]
chick man
it is even recommended by multiple
leading chiropractors and doctors of
sleep medicine as a go-to solution for
improving your sleep Helix is offering
up to 20 off all their mattress orders
and two free grouping no two free
pillows for our listeners go to Helix
sleep.com slash Burr this is their best
offer yet and it won't last long with
Helix uh better sleep starts now
all right this is all we got left here
this is the last one
uh um it's fight camp
all right let's be honest we could all
use a little more motivation when it
comes to working out allow me to
introduce myself my name is Humpty uh
allow me to introduce you to fight Camp
fight Camp is interactive at home boxing
I don't want to actually get in a fight
I don't want to fill out applications I
don't want things to happen they bring
the best workout in the world into your
home and make it fun
this is great you can get it you could
be like [__] in boxer shape with no
blows to the Head
right
so you can see that gold digging [__]
coming for your eight pack explore
thousands of workouts led by expert
trainers with Decades of experience
teaching proper boxing form and
technique yeah for the next time you go
to a [__] Laker game fight Camp has
uh has live punch counting stats that
motivate you by counting every punch
throughout your workout and pushing you
to meet your goals each round as you
progress I'm gonna [__] do this man
I like those boxing workouts I used to
tape fights
I know I've told this before all of my
stories I've told at this point I used
to tape fights and then I would re-watch
the fights and when the boxers were
fighting I would I would skip rope and
then in between rounds I would rest like
they did and at first I could only do
like [__] one and a half rounds and
then I worked my way all the way up I
think the longest was like eight rounds
and then I was just like I I can't
[__] do this
and I'm thinking these guys are actually
fighting each other all right as you
progress you'll un unlock achievements
and you can go head to head against
other members within whether they're
across the country or across the living
room one of the best things about fight
Camp is that it makes boxing assess
accessible to everyone no matter what
Fitness level you're at what your age is
or what your experience with boxing is
you can do it all right you can get up
off the couch
and you're going to have a great time so
join the biggest boxing community in the
world without leaving your home the
holiday season this holiday season
you'll get oh Jesus this is some old
copy uh the holiday season oh it's
Valentine's Day it's a holiday too
don't vagina shame me
get me some [__] stuff so I know you
still love me
I like when you express your love and
stuff uh you'll also get a heart rate
monitor
Daddy I gotta sit out and a premium jump
rope oh a premium Jump Rope for free
yeah when I wish I can't you use the
extension cord
if you could get it away from your
mother uh that's an additional 148
dollar value for free fight Camp
packages start at just 99 they also
offer some great financing options so
you can get started for as low as nine
dollars a month to get started and to
get your free gifts with purchase go to
fightcamp.com Bird that's fight cap
fightcamp.com
dude that that movie there's a few that
stayed with me there's some like you
know that I saw that uh
you even know like just you watch like a
horror movie and it like doesn't scare
you as much as it's just sort of like a
spectacle yeah but then there's the ones
that have you like looking over your
shoulder right
um now what to me like I I feel like my
theory with horror movies is that the
special effects got so good they forgot
how to build suspense because back in
the day when all they had was a guy in a
wood a wig with like a [__] ax in the
woods
um they had to build like that uh with
the [__] music and looking around the
corner and oh there's nobody there and
then the old school you turn around and
there he is like they used to build that
up like I got it I got one for you okay
a low uh a
um
a sort of like I guess a B-side horror
movie I saw this movie one night called
Dark Knight of the Scarecrow okay yeah
you ever saw that from the 70s right oh
my god with a guy who's mentally yes
there was always a guy like mentally ill
yeah somebody always got raped right and
all those 70 ones it was it was super
[__] that's a great movie dude that
movie Scared the [__] [__] out of me
it was basically this mentally
challenged dude yeah something happened
they blamed it on the mentally
challenged dude and then they killed him
and then the next because he hidden the
Scarecrow and then they kill him
spoiler alert yeah and then like the
next [__] day
like a few days later like after he's
dead and uh you know the townsfolks
somehow you know
I don't know they just buy the story of
the [__] the football playing
[__] who killed him all of a sudden
like the wife of one of the guys like
the next day or something like that is
just like oh honey hey thanks for uh you
know putting that scarecrow out in the
field he's like I didn't put a scarecrow
on the field so he goes oh what's that
they turn they just and they just cut to
the Scarecrow on the feeling they just
go Jake like that I was like yeah
I [__] hate that and then it was like
it's weird because you should be rooting
for this mentally challenged dude but
now he's like dead
and I'm like nah yeah it's weird that
was a weird movie because I I kind of
didn't know
it's like I'm supposed to be rooting for
him but you're playing this music like
he's the bad guy now yeah it kind of
like it gets away from itself a little
bit they were much more suspenseful back
in the 70s yeah they really built it up
I mean yeah now everything is jump
scares and loud noises and bang bang
dude I gotta wear earplugs to the movies
because I have tinnitus from drums and
helicopters I actually do something
[__] I had a four-wheeler I told the
helicopter out with and it [__]
backfired like a gunshot my [__] ear
I know thank God it came back down
though came back down so then I just
gotta I gotta chill okay you're not no I
was worried
you're such a dick
you've been a dick for [__] 30 years
oh now you're gonna be the victim you
call me up you beg me to be on your
podcast I come on here and now you're
[__] all over me
making a fool out of me
up it looks like a goatee growing into a
beard why does it go out so [__] far
that has bugged me for like seven seven
which is my intention I'm glad too many
guys do it this way I'm glad you shave
what are you doing you were out of
control with that thing what are you
talking about the giant [__] Kris
Kringle Red Beard you had for a while
the big Fenway Park show you didn't like
that I swear to God when I got to the
Fenway Park show the only thing in my
head was I hope he shaved the [__]
beard I hope he's not gonna go up like
that because I saw you a few nights
earlier at giggles and I'm like that
Bear's out of control man he looks like
a [__] I gotta pick I gotta yeah I
just I got it lined up before I went up
there but it was still making a
statement dude you look like you put
your face in something dude you look
like the guy and that Rudolph the
Red-Nosed Reindeer cartoon from the kids
the one who's walking around like that's
what I think of when I say when your
Beard's that big you know it's funny I
used to I used to get teased oh like
everybody loved those [__] claymation
things so they came out I'm like ah [__]
is the Heat Miser on tonight it goes 10
days of my childhood right 10 straight
day hey Bill Murphy ah Mr Heat Miser
you know when I was little I'd be like I
don't look like that guy which is the
worst wait you had a beard when you were
a kid no the Heat Miser oh you're
talking about the guy who his hair was
up like that was all [__] red and all
sticking out and all that [__] when you
were younger I don't know how you were
as a kid but when you were in your early
20s at Nick's back in the day your hair
was still doing that your hair was like
really up yeah I remember describing it
was definitely a race talking to
somebody like hey if you worked with
Bill Burr yet and they're like who's
Bill Burr and I'm like you know he's
that kid you know he's young he looks
like the guy from Simply Red and they'd
be like oh that kid and I'm like yeah
that kid yeah yeah it was a bad period
for me we all had a bad picture we all I
was gonna say we all have bad experience
um yeah that was probably
um yeah I was still in college yeah you
were you were shy that was me yeah but
that was me subtly rebelling that was
that was me that was like how
introverted I was against who I'm not I
don't know why parents walking around
going oh yeah Dad
no I'm not gonna be a dentist Dad here
suck it
here
you probably there was something going
on I don't even know dude but I was I
was um when I when you first met me dude
I was a [__] mess dude I was no
that's wrong that's not correct no that
doesn't go along with my memory when I
first met you oh you met me you were a
normal like easy going kind of shy kid
oh absolutely no I remember that's who I
thought I was that's who I thought I was
I would that was me no that was who I
became
because all the [__] that had me I
became that guy so I got along with
people so they would stop [__] with
me but that was not who I was at all
I remember a distinct change in you
around
1999-2000.
where you me uh Wayne pravity went to
birds on Franklin rest his soul Wayne
privity you know what earlier when you
got a little dream about him a little
bit that I can't I can't hear any
Goodfellas reference without thinking a
win I know you know you had a dream
about us yeah well I had this long
[__] up dream it was just a [__] up
drink I can't even like I uh am I even
gonna tell you I was for some reason
I was doing a roast for some football
team which I've done that before for
sports teams it's not the easiest gig so
I was doing it and I said something the
whole [__] room got quiet like I
offended somebody and then this woman
came over with their kids and for some
reason they were there in the locker
room and she's just and she came over it
was worse than her yelling me she just
like hugged me and was like crying on
the side of my face I'm like what's the
matter she goes why would you say those
things I'm like what are you [__] she
goes I got my kids here I'm like this
guy's showering you're in a locker room
I did that and some I forget and it
progressed somehow in the end I was in
one of my old apartments in New York
and Wayne brevity who I loved to death
unfortunately passed away came walking
through the door and then these two West
Highland Terriers came running out that
they were mine we used to have West
Highland Terriers when I was a kid oh
okay and we used to tease the [__] out
of him and they would attack company and
I was totally uh
freaking out that they were going to
bite Wayne and they didn't they came out
and they went nice yeah so what that is
I think that part of the dream
represents how I came up and then I'm
realizing that my kids are not going to
be like me they're actually going to be
nice and not be [__] lunatics I
understand that as far as the woman
crying on me I don't know what that is
she's probably like you know you're just
a hurt kid stop hurting other people you
[__] you're too old to be doing this
yeah I don't you know uh yeah I don't
know and then the naked guys is just par
for the course guys just when have you
not had a dream with naked guys oh yeah
I mean it's doesn't everybody I mean I
dream every night of naked men although
you know Wayne visiting you a dream I
totally believe that when we see dead
people in our dreams that's really them
like I believe that
like every maybe once we could have said
something the [__] [__] he just
was standing there he wasn't even
smiling he just opened the door and
there he was he's just letting you know
he's watching
dude I used to hang out with Wayne
property like every single [__] day
went out when I lived out here
you know the first time and then the
second time I I hung with that we joined
a gym together we were at this place
called Bulldog gym I used to go there
too yeah La Brea was a great [__]
just awesome I mean what everything's
something else now but that Hollywood
gym that went around the corner Rogan I
think used to go to that one yeah Rogan
went to the one across the street
Rogan's always had a gym we all know
that that [__] guy has been just
when I met him he was like that he must
have been voted like most likely to be
jacked his whole life I mean there is
something to be said though about never
stopping working out and stuff because
those guys they they yeah it's like
elastic it goes back yeah yeah yeah so
like I kind of I I me I'm like a
cardiogram as far as my working on it I
wish I wish I had his his discipline is
is insane the first time I met Rogan was
at uh a place called Barnaby's in
Somerville do you ever work there it was
in the back when it was slummerville
back when it wasn't yeah it wasn't a fun
place to be no it wasn't it was in the
basement of a restaurant called red
bones and it was called uh yeah it was
called
no I'm sorry I'm confusing two different
places no that's right yeah it was
called Barnaby's and um it was a tiny
little basement it was Dungey but they
got crowds and uh Tommy Dunham used to
book it another guy yeah funny guy he
used to book me down in Weymouth on
Route three at the bomo remember he
would be just leaning he'd come and he'd
just be on the couch a big guy
you just be like
you're opening
you funny
yeah like I hope so he had like that mob
Vibe yeah he did he did he used to book
it and um
he so one night we were there I'd never
met Rogan Rogan was there too and uh
Tommy goes hey you see that guy over
there I go yeah he goes uh his name's
Joe Rogan and I was like oh yeah he goes
he's doing one of your bits and I'm like
really he goes yeah he's [__] [__]
he thinks you sucking he doesn't care
and I'm like what he goes you should say
something to him and I'm like which bit
of mine is he doing he's like oh he's
doing the cat bit and I'm like [__] so I
go up to Joe and when I get closer to
Joe and I see like you know he's wearing
a t-shirt but you can still see this
like rips like you know there's wrinkles
where there shouldn't be wrinkles
between like the shoulder and the chest
you know what I mean so I go up to him
and I have no extra Delta yeah and I go
hey uh I go why is Tommy trying to trick
me into [__] with you and he goes oh
because he knows I kick your ass
oh you you figured it out but yeah
before I got to him I realized oh okay
you know when I got closer to Joe and
there's that like an aura of don't [__]
with that guy yes so I I realized it so
I feel the wind from his last
you ever see a spinning heel kick I mean
it's just yeah to this day yeah but I
didn't want to you know I'm already
there and I go hey so why is that why is
Tommy trying to trick me in to [__] with
you and he chew on me yeah he goes uh
because you know I kick your ass
and so I said well you try because you
know it's Boston yes I can't just suffer
go throw away my dignity I still have to
even though I know he'd kill me I still
have to put forward you simulate raping
bikers man you had a rip oh my voice
just went up you had a rap and when it
happened I really lost faith in you I
really thought why is now he's doing
what I did
um so he says I I [__] kill you and I
go dude well you try and he he Loops me
up and down he goes dude I would [__]
destroy you and I'm like wow okay he's
really confident about this I go I'm
just curious why are you so sure that
you would destroy me he goes Tommy knows
I am a champion at taekwondo and all
this stuff and so I went oh really and
then now he's now I'm thinking he's a
little bit full of [__] the way he's
talking because he's so right he's
talking about how great he is so I'm
like uh we start talking about martial
arts movies and there was a scene and an
episode of kung fu I think I go like
that scene where the guy jumps up and he
kicks the kicks the beam and he goes
yeah I could do that and I went come on
he goes no I could do that and and we're
in the basement right and there are
these these beams that are above us and
they're they're like I don't know it's
still a ceiling it's not like you know
you have to be six seven to walk around
in there I mean it's still so uh I go
what about that beam right there you
know and he goes uh sure he takes a
couple steps back he jumps up and he
does like in midair like kind of a split
and he hits it with his foot and I don't
mean he hit it I mean he hit it hard
where dust came off of it and I was like
holy [__] dude wow that would have been
your head yeah under your chin he kicks
through your head I'm like wow dude
that's amazing and then you know we hung
he came into the circle after that like
he was in my class yeah I always I uh
you guys had you had a really good class
uh you Rogan uh Robbie Prince Robbie
Prince laletta Greg Fitzsimmons Greg
Fitzsimmons uh Paul Elwell uh well
Elwell Tommy Dunham there's a couple
other guys one of my first road gigs
ever Paul Elwell I opened for him oh
yeah yeah and he wanted to go water
skiing
I we were on this Lake and he goes watch
this he goes I'm just going to keep
talking about water skiing because it
was the end of the summer and everybody
put their boats away and he basically
said I'm gonna keep talking about water
skiing and one of these wives is gonna
bug their husband and we're gonna go
water skiing I go all right and he goes
up there
yeah
and he just started doing I don't know
how you work in water skiing into every
other [__] bit but he did it and by
the time we got off stage you know he
ends up thinking this [__] woman
comes up and you see the guy standing
there like you know I guess I could take
the cover off a blah blah we stayed an
extra day and this guy just [__] took
him water skiing dragged me across the
lake that was his his bonus I said so he
was doing it because he genuinely wanted
to go water skiing he wasn't doing it
like I'm gonna talk about water skiing
the whole time just to see if I can do
it oh he evidently water skied huh I
thought you meant like the we used to uh
dare each other to do [__] no he just
wanted the crowd to give him some free
water skiing and he just went up there
it was amazing wow yeah I remember that
guy remember he bought this Eagle Talon
remember that Eagle Talon he was into
this Chrysler car yeah it was a car and
he was saying like this is the [__]
car to buy I don't know [__] about cars
either yeah
I've never seen that one come across a
Mecum auctioned do you know what those
are no they auction off old cars coming
up I'm free of all that stuff
not worrying about sports or cars or
anything it's just like yeah but you
fill it up with something
yeah I do I do oh a little shame in that
you look down at them yeah no there's a
little you look down at the ground it
was that a camera
I go yeah but you fill it up with
something else you literally just go
like this like yeah yeah I do
what what was that about Let's uh let's
explore that
you're too old to be reading comic books
and you know it don't you I've actually
been selling off Comics it's turned into
a fun little hobby on the side it just
so happens that a bunch of the comics
that I bought when I was a kid like at
cover price that I've kept in
participating conditions you know bagged
and boarded because of this boarded me
uh you they go in a plastic bag with a
board behind it to keep it flat
did they say BNB in the industry they
just say bagged and boarded Bill do you
go to Comic Con I have I have that issue
BNB
but I've been I've been selling them off
and uh it's not like you know a lot of
money but it's fun it's a good little
hobby it's also isn't it great though to
free up that space in your house no just
in your house yeah I I I'm I'm really
big into getting rid of [__] and and not
accepting new [__]
you know what I mean people trying to
give you hey you want this does your
wife work against you on that because my
wife does that all the time like someone
could be giving away something and my
wife will be like yeah we'll take it and
we fight about this because you know
like a neighbor hey we're getting rid of
our refrigerator we're getting a new one
and she'll tell me this oh we can maybe
part of it is because I don't want to
have to deal with moving this freaking
thing into the house but we have two
refrigerators why do we need a third
refrigerator we get rid of the one in
the garage and use this one it's like a
six thousand dollar refrigerator and I'm
like honey why do you think they're
getting rid of it exactly it leaks
there's nothing wrong with it if it's
such a good refrigerator why are they
giving it to us right they're not even
selling it right
yeah they want that thing out of the
house that's a horror movie right there
that's like the what about Bob's a
[__] refrigerator sorry hooked up
there what about Bob's a refrigeration
see this is what it's like to hang with
the Boston guy you have to call yourself
on your [__] before he does yeah you
can't show any weakness and you're gonna
grab it right away
no my uh you know women they're into
stuff the way guys are into real guys
are into sports my wife is into
Contraptions sorry comic books she needs
all kinds of devices gadgets everything
from label makers well you know why that
is why is she feels like you're not man
enough so she feels you have to she has
to cover I see she has to like say
you're like 60 a man she has to buy 40
more gadgets
and raise it and I'm gonna put you on
the spot because I need a punch for
something because I've got an idea for a
bit okay I realize she's been tricking
me for years
to get me to do yard work and [__] by
going hey honey um you know on a
Saturday I wake up days full I don't
know what I'm gonna do with myself but
she has plans in her head and she'll be
like uh what do you want to do do you
want to clean out the garage do you want
to mow the lawn
and all of a sudden that's what you do
to a toddler yes yes he says no win what
do you want to do right you want to sit
here and eat or go to bed and she does
this to me and I've been falling for it
for years because my brain's like that
big and I but now I'm like wow okay so
as a bit I would say I turned it around
on her you know so honey what do you
want me to do blank or blank so should I
put in having the college girl next door
blow me or something else I mean but I
I'm trying to keep [__] out of my
Act it's been too long right Robbie
princess [__] me years like there's
no joke I can't put a [__] into
well maybe that's your calling card
maybe that's when people ask about your
hobbies you look down and shame because
for all these years you've never been
yourself
I think you kind of like I should
embrace that flower bloom I should
embrace the difference what do you want
to do suck my dick or [__] ride my
ride my [__] right I mean that's the
easy that's the bar room joke yeah
um
Tony saragusa of the Ravens rest his
soul I just watched it every one of his
every one of his stories he told on that
30 for 30 was so then I told the guy to
shove it up his ass
today you know what I say buddy kiss my
ass and I was like
all the people I love how you throw at a
sports name and expect me to I don't
expect
I just like the look of confusion I
didn't know if you were talking about an
actor or what I said Tony saragusa from
the Ravens oh I don't know if the Ravens
is a band or if that's a comic book is
that a superhero isn't there a raven I
don't know of a raven but that is there
a crow there was a crow there's a hawk
guy yeah but that's DC I'm not into DC
I'm a Marvel guy dude come on River
stream [__] any basic rooting for the
Yankees come on man
yeah that's the best one there is yeah
is he yeah no he's all right I think
he's overrated Batman now there's all
kinds of great stories there he's got
all this money yeah he bags some chicks
every once in a while he wants to jump
over the fence he's got Robin he jumps
over the Finish he swings his leg over
he's very Progressive
it's got some he's got a cool car a Cool
Motorcycle and a boat he's got all the
toys Superman's got none of that
[__] nerd he's down there working at
the paper oh we got a scoop for you okay
this horn Rim glasses
Superman is basically any your average
[__] Juice Head at a Gold's Gym with
a cape on that's all he is you know
what's interesting although he does have
a Fortress of Solitude he does which I
like the tone of that like this [__] is
driving me crazy I know that's his 18
holes of golf
you know because he's so [__] super
he can't deal with anybody else so he
can't hang with him he's still an orphan
still an orphan he's not an orphan he's
an orphan what are you talking about an
orphan Superman's not an orphan he has
parents see now this that's what comic
book Geeks live for they just died like
I just wandered into a sports convention
and I'm like Lauren Greene was his dad
who Lauren Green
Lauren Green was Christopher Reeve
Superman's Dad no that was Marlon Brando
he was like get out of here
you little [__]
I love how like the planet's blowing up
and they can get him out of there but
they can't why didn't he just get on the
thing he got out of it he tried to warn
everybody this big why don't they make
the plane I don't know what they make
the Black Box on them I just want 80s
comedies on you just went full Seinfeld
yeah
Wasn't That Seinfeld well that was my
impression but I was doing bad 80s
comedy in the Seinfeld voice in a
Seinfeld voice but no Seinfeld
are we gonna talk watch your mouth do
your [__] jokes how dare you even say
that man's name
do you know one time I opened no no oh
yes that was his adopted dad
yeah Glenn Ford was his adopted dad but
his his biological dad was um brendo
yeah now I've lost all credibility for
being I'm waiting for a board game to
come on the table
foreign
tell me tell me your craziest Road story
dude you know what's funny I can't even
remember him anymore I don't know I
don't know craziest Road story is far
like what like crazy things that happen
like getting ready for this I was
talking to Robbie and I'm like give me
some stories I know he's gonna ask me
some stuff so no it's well I put a few
in my pocket just in case that I didn't
know if you'd heard of like Nazi stories
Bob Seibel stories so you don't really
want to hear my story you just want to
tell your story oh you're the
psychoanalyst in you is really out of
control well maybe you're just an easy
guy to figure out
wow well played well played yes I'm not
in mystery yeah I used to [__] bully
me at Bennigan's
[__] do your little like you couldn't
tell you were amazing are you talking
about on the trivia machine no no I'm
[__] with you you were always a nice
guy you were a dick but that you know
not everybody was a dick I know I know I
know relax you know who didn't know
Bobby Kelly what I would do to Bobby
Kelly [__] that I would do to you and do
to other people but Bobby Kelly didn't
get what I was doing and I didn't know
for like it's all about respect dude
for a full two years he thought I hated
him
where like he never talked to me and one
time we were together and I said uh
dude how come you don't talk to me
what's going on and he was like well I
know you don't like me and I said where
do you get that from he goes the way you
do you say this and you say that you do
this and I'm like dude I'm just [__]
with you we do that to everybody and he
and I felt really what did he say what
did I say it wasn't what no what did he
say he was like oh well okay and then
everything was fine and but yeah it was
the weirdest thing I and it bummed me
out I didn't intend to hurt his feelings
for so long
I'm sure he got over it dude
okay the kid like three or four fathers
growing up so I mean he was going to
take [__]
yeah and the guy with the bike horn is
walking around going okay [__]
boy Goodwill Hunting was boring to Bobby
Kelly wow it's like dude only one guy
with a wrench
I lived with him man
in New York right yeah we almost [__]
killed each other and our friendship got
stronger simultaneously it was the most
[__] up
yeah dude we would too like Beyond
broken toys oh wow and we were living in
a in a a railroad apartment and it was
somebody else's so I got the
walk-through bedroom and he was sleeping
in the living room and we would just
like basically we just all living on top
of each other we [__] animals do it
one of those days dude the day so let me
hear Bob Seibel I love rest his soul
Bobby's side you sure you want to hear
it or am I just projecting my stories on
to you like I used sincerely genuinely
want to hear the story are you just
saying that now because I've thrown it
up and if you don't take it you look
like a bad host I don't want to hear it
um
he has a new book out no I I do want to
hear it I I miss all of those days too
Bobby Seibel and I greatest guy in the
world so nice I mean genuine just Heart
of Gold but he had no like he would not
exist in 2023 like he would not be able
to navigate all the the current thinking
in the current culture
he he we were doing a gig in Connecticut
and we were put up in a Holiday Inn and
he got there before I did good gig
holiday in yeah it's a nice year it's
nice absolutely absolutely continental
breakfast that's a decent hotel room had
a microwave
so he got there before I did and I'm
checking in he's already in the room the
guy gives me the key and I walk down uh
whatever room it was I go to put the key
in and as I'm putting the key in there's
this family coming down the hall behind
me
most purebred family you can imagine
like white white Mom and Dad everybody's
like blonde and they look just like out
of a 60s yeah exactly and as I pushed
the door open they're like basically
right behind me so they can look into
the room and cybel's lying on the bed
naked and he's got his dick and he's
holding his dick and twirling his dick
and he's he's like Burt Reynolds like a
Burt Reynolds layout all hairy and [__]
and he looks at me with a family behind
me and he goes Paco get in here you
filthy [__] sucker and his family just
like freezes and I'm like God and there
was no time to say like he's a comedian
he's kidding or anything I just like ran
in and slammed the door which made it
look even worse oh no yeah what their
faces just dropped I from what I saw
they would just like you know the little
kids little kids like Jesus yeah that's
my favorite Bob Cy Bell story oh yeah
there was a lot of like unwanted male
nudity growing up in the 70s and [__]
like that like I still I'm still never
forget this this guy we were coming out
of a Red Sox game
and you remember when mooning was a
thing oh yeah these bunch of drunks on
this big yellow bus
had taken this had taken this thing to
the game and this guy in the end decided
he was
he was gonna Moon the crowd so you
remember those little Windows you'd
bring down dude he sticks his hairy ass
out the window to the point like his
balls are kind of hanging out too and
remember just looking up and seeing that
I don't know my dad going like ah Jesus
Christ honey look honey look there he
goes that Christ I go say I wish I had a
pole
yeah there was a lot dude I did a fight
of [__] construction job one time you
did yeah and this [__] guy only
lasted like [__] eight days I was
just like I was we were Roofing man I
couldn't it was oh so that bit is based
on a real thing oh dude I just
remembered I could not eat enough
sandwiches I was just still hungry and I
was just I was red as a lobster and this
[__] guy he had like on a pair of
like Dickies and they had this giant
like [__] hole here like you usually
have on your knee just to the right or
left of his junk and he wouldn't wear
underwear and one day
one day I'm sitting there picking up
something and he stepped over it and the
hole moved like junk and went back and I
just remember looking at him that was
back when I didn't say anything like I
he's also like my brother's no he was he
was the boss's brother so I couldn't
[__] say anything but I wanted to be
like dude what the [__]
they ruin your sandwich
dude I know if you got it were you
eating like were you like dude I could
pick his junk out of a lineup like
that's how much it burned into my brain
because I was literally down there and
it was just like
and it was just kind of like uh now
looking back it's like why did you do
what the [__] is going on with you he
had a no that's definitely no like you
can't look at that every day when you're
putting on your jeans and not know
that's gonna happen Dude full package
uncircumcised oh just see that's even
worse hang in there like a condom
you know what I've learned though don't
ever make fun of uncircumcised dicks in
mixed company because you don't know it
was you another [__] no I'm snowflake
no no no no no no no that's what I mean
I just want to say snowflake I was with
a group of people and I was [__] on
you know
uncircumcised penis and all of a sudden
this one couple got quiet and she her
name's cat she looked at her husband
Scott and I was like oh [__] I [__] up
I go hey I'm sorry I didn't mean to you
know I'm sure it's lovely but what do
you do Oh I thought you should say that
she wanted him to get circumcised and he
did and they [__] it up no
dedicated to that I only know from what
I've read about Elvis in his
uncircumcised penis I guess it does tear
what does the foreskin no it doesn't
according to the biographies I've read
yeah that doesn't make any sense
look I'm not a doctor I'm just telling
you so you're saying
Elvis would play into his buddies that
he was having sex and his dick would
tear that's because he was having so
much sex could be yeah he's putting it
in their butt
no lube it's a 50s there was no lube
there was a war going on in the 50s what
do you mean to the 70s 70s
why don't he was [__] that much when
he was on the pills he was that fat yeah
I don't think so I don't think it's so
I don't think his dick was getting up to
the higher registers you doing coke now
no it's just like I thought my nose was
running and all I need is to have like a
big snot bubble coming out so I thought
I'd turn my head
all right we're gonna go back to the
book yeah let's go back to the book
I'll be honest with you dude I didn't
even know you could read
you're not the first one you know and
that's just that's part of them I've
been telling people
you know other Comics that we started
dude Todd wrote a book and it's really
[__] good it's like they all just
Todd yeah like and it's really insulting
I know but you think about isn't it all
like so much of who you are is based on
how you did in school and then you just
carry that and where your social status
was so you just like unless you were
like the quarterback of the popular kids
most people just kind of walk around
thinking they're morons unless they
created they went into their ego and
they just created this other guy that
just [__] knows everything so dick
joke Comics can't have any intelligence
it just assumes uh they're just drunk
[__] no my my thing with like I
never uh looked at it that way
because I remember getting back to Rogan
yeah when Rogan was young like uh you
know all of those guys that couldn't
follow him would [__] on him in his act
and say oh he's still he just goes out
there and it's filth filth filth and I
went up I mean I went up to the Kowloon
and the first time I saw him it's like
this guy's not dirt like this thought if
this thought behind it it's not a dick
joke right a dick joke is just a lazy
thing I always quote this joke that one
of the first ones I saw Rogan do that I
just [__] loved was he was talking
about you know women complaining that
guys you know didn't know what they were
doing in bed and he goes ladies that
kind of works both ways he goes you ever
have uh you see him guys you ever have a
woman give you a hand job he goes it's
like brushing you brushing your teeth
with your left hand
hahaha
then of course he expounded on that and
I was like dude that is such a great
because everybody at some point for
whatever reason you're like what if I
try what if I lost this arm and had a
brush my teeth it's like you pushing
right
um so he had like you know that that
Tiger's [__] thing was oh I mean that
was amazing that was that was a month
because he sounded like a [__] tiger
yeah and I also remember like his stage
presence the first time I saw him at the
Kowloon and then I saw him he had this
set in Aspen
back when they had that Comedy Festival
and he just walked on stage killing and
the only thing that sucked was this
[__] guy doing the sound kept turning
it down
and I came up to him as he was yelling
and he thought he was helping yeah he
thought he was helping I just remember
and it was like really bring like you
still felt the power of it but this guy
really he was turning down his
lightsaber right so I said something to
the guy and he goes like oh yeah he's
like I compressed the hell out of him I
was and I just like I I said to my God I
wish she didn't
because it was it was like you could
just see was like it was like turning
down AC DC at that point you know you
know Joe was a younger guy it was like a
different like that whole energy thing
um
yeah yeah I loved I've like all like
there was so many guys from back then I
remember you telling the crowd to shut
up because they were laughing too much I
was like Jesus Christ really yeah you
were telling a story and they were
laughing shut up shut up I gotta get to
the good part because they were laughing
too early and I just remember I was in
awe of all that going like like I'm up
there just trying to get laughs this
guy's getting so many laughs he has to
tell the crowd to be quiet to stop
laughing so there's all of that stuff
kind of burned in there and uh one of
the things that I loved was how much you
[__] with laletta oh yeah um there was
this comedian Boston Jim laletta and he
he would uh great guy great guy oh boy
give you the shirt off his back here
comes some stories if you got to go
great guy I've got a great guy but
that's what I look Jim we used to hang
out all the time I love Jim he was great
um
he he just happens to have Neon Bright
buttons that he basically begs to be
[__] with like he just loves it I mean
I like I said I've got nothing but
respect but Jim not only is he hilarious
but he would give you the shirt off his
back if he needed it he's always there
but he was one of those big-hearted guys
you couldn't help but tease him like he
used to do this thing uh for a while I
didn't have a car
so and he lived in Roslindale and he
would drive me home from Boston to
Revere just to be a nice guy he had this
Hyundai this white Hyundai and he'd be
dropping me off at like two o'clock in
the morning I lived on this busy street
and I would get out of the car and I
would kick his back Fender as a way of
saying hey go [__] yourself you know
just like a funny thanks for the ride
and uh and he would yell at the window
don't [__] hit my car like that and
then the next time I talk to him he go
dude why do you always kick my car and I
go I'm just you know saying thanks he
goes don't do that so this went on for
10 rides and then what I love about Jim
is he keeps giving you a ride yes the
solution yeah stop giving Todd yes a
ride nope gonna keep giving her a ride
and I keep doing it harder and harder
and then like after so many times we're
pulling up to my house and he goes wait
before you get out of the car I go what
he goes listen to me I'm asking you as a
friend and I'm telling you I will not
give you another ride if you kick my car
and I said okay I didn't know it
bothered you that much I'm just [__]
with you you know that he goes I know I
know you're just trying you think you're
[__] with me but it really pisses me
off so please I'm begging you you're
gonna destroy our friendship if you kick
my car now okay fine I get out of the
car I walk around like Joe Rogan I hit
that I kicked that thing as hard as I
possibly could like you could hear
he gets so mad he jumps out of the car
and he starts chasing me down the street
he's running after me and it was during
the time where everybody's wearing those
Sam Kinison long jackets and his coat's
like flopping in the wind like Batman is
just chasing me he's certainly I jump
back into his car because I got so ahead
of him and I drove away
he's standing in front of my house in
Rivera two o'clock in the morning like
[__] oh my God thieves like the
Charlie Brown just couldn't [__] win
I miss those days dude um me too hey how
how many how much time we've done I
don't even know because I've just been
laughing here
54. look at that I can feel an hour wow
huh just like that you're like so dude I
am like oh sorry I was talking over here
that's all right yeah shut the [__] up
when I'm
dude it's amazing thanks I'm proud of
you thanks thanks man most people could
sit around and they complain
but uh God didn't give you the facial
hair to grow a full beard
you know this is a choice or like the
fashion sense to not buy that hoodie
right A lot of people would sit around
and complain about that but not you a
lot of thought went into this yeah
that's coming from a place to love if
you could just shut up
I'm really proud of you thanks man
because I got to be honest with you for
the longest time I thought you were one
of the dumbest people I ever met
and there was no [__] way that you
could even write a sentence forget about
a full book that kept my attention
you're doing a signing I am doing a song
that was me saying I love you yes I I
and I love you back and I love you back
so much I'm not even gonna fight it I'm
not gonna try to fight it I'm just gonna
let you have your moment all right ah
that was some [__] my moment [__] you
I'll let you have your moment like
you're letting me win no I just I know
better than to go back and forth with
you in certain areas I don't act like
you respect me tell me tell me about
your life books hey before we get to me
let's let's talk about you a little bit
you know people are already peeking and
there's another podcast coming in I'm
sorry okay
um yes I'm doing a pie I'm sorry you're
doing your live signing stop resetting
like we're gonna edit this we're not
you go okay back to one and Action Line
sorry yeah I'm doing a sign
I can't talk I'm doing a signing
February 18th at a place called possman
books in Ponce City Market in Atlanta
from one to three
um hoping to get a lot of people hoping
a lot of everybody who's watching this
that's amazing yeah isn't it you've
wrought a book you're doing a book
signing look at you yeah you gotta get
some horn room glass
foreign
Todd Parker everybody the book is called
billionaire Boogeyman this is a boogie
man boogie sorry Jesus dude sorry I'm
stupid billion
fair point it's literally written the
answer is literally here and I still
it's called Billy man boogie guys
billionaire Boogeyman a novel by Todd
Parker look for him in store that's the
name of the store well it's on Amazon
everywhere on Amazon Amazon is where you
want to get it fast if you want to get
me signed decided in person go to
postman books and Ponce City Market in
Atlanta on February 18th that's [__]
amazing thanks man I love you brother
thanks for coming on thanks you guys for
watching have a great weekend you [__]
hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's the Monday Morning podcast for
Monday uh February 16th and I'm back in
the USA Baby
finally I should say I'm back home
I'm back home and home is where the
heart is don't you think I actually I
have a new recorder I don't know if the
levels are too high here I have no
[__] idea I can't really hear myself
um the old girl finally died I mentioned
last week the Olympus LS 10 is what I
had and uh they're all the way up to the
14th so now I got the 14 which I'm I
seem to be enjoying so far although I
can't stand the [__] lady
voice
every button that you hit it goes like
recording
back to main menu and it's this [__]
English Lady it's like what the [__] are
you doing like why
when the [__] did an American accent
just become like you can't have that
you can't have it on like your uh like
all these [__] one of those things
that I advertise on on this this podcast
it's like they try to give you like uh
for your voicemail you have some sort of
international just not from America
voice and all of a sudden it makes it
sound like you're like yeah wow I like
this company they must be [__] people
over globally
all over the world the [__] did you
did you hear this the [__]
did you hear the outgoing message oh
hello welcome to Pinkberry
all of a sudden I think I'm getting a
higher class [__] yogurt
because what because it's got an English
accent what the [__] is it with the
goddamn English that everybody thinks
it's so [__]
you know what it is it has to do with
the fact that we're over here on our own
goddamn Island
all right and if it actually had some
sort of French accent all it does is
remind you that you can't [__] speak
the language but what like English all
of a sudden it starts to sound a little
hoity-toity
you know who I blame for all this I
blame Madonna
all right
let me tell you something about that
[__]
lady there all right
she's from [__] Detroit
she grew up outside of that [__] hell
hole
hey by the way you know something well
let's complete the thought bill for the
love of God see it through okay she grew
up outside of that [__] hellhole she
does a couple of [__] whoopty dudes
around the world singing a dumbass song
in her mustard colored pumps and all of
a sudden she's got a [__] English
accent it's annoying
all right
I've lived out here for [__] coming
up on eight years
all right
I still like I still sound like I'm
going down the turnpike
you know I was just over in Asia that
had come back sounded like I was from
[__] India
you know
I mean my daughter how much he is
searching
how bad was your [__] childhood how
bad was this country
that you felt you had you had you moved
to another one and then you took on
their goddamn accent like they wouldn't
notice
why am I jumping all over her
all right favorite Madonna song what
would you like would you like the guilty
pleasure or would you like the one that
I actually like the musicianship
what's the guilty pleasure one
oh God it was one of our earlier ones
you know
before she got into all of that I don't
know what the [__] she was doing you
know before the sex book
you know or it's just like you know I'll
[__] anything hurt those years it's like
we get it we get it all right you like
you like dick you like women too you
like dick and women you know you like
that [__] fat guy in uh
in Monty Python get a better get a
bucket I'm gonna throw up except it's
with dicks
you know it's like this new thing I've
noticed with comedy with women like
that's like this [__] it's considered
edgy
if they talk about their clams and it's
just like you you know with all due
respect you just sort of a bar hack at
that point aren't you are you just doing
dick jokes because it's a vagina all of
a sudden you know they're taking control
of their bodies it's like you I don't
give a [__] what you're doing you're
doing a dick joke mine is the dick with
the [__] it's the same [__] it's
like Sam Smith with the Tom Petty song
right it's the same [__] thing
no I stay with me
um
it's just a [__] dick joke could
everybody stop losing their [__]
minds over a dick joke because now it's
a [__] joke it's the same [__] joke
blah blah blah I so let me get this
straight if you're shooting a load in
somebody's face you're just a [__]
you know a blue comic but if you're
taking the load to the face you're
groundbreaking is that how it works with
you goddamn kids today well hey we'll
pop out to you
by the way I'm just [__] with Sam
Smith because that song doesn't sound
anything like the other song and I guess
when you speed up one and slow down the
other then yeah yeah then I guess it is
the same sound
it's the same song but like at no point
that I ever listened to it and think of
that Tom Petty song and not to mention
Sam Smith song was way [__] better
and you know there's people out there
that actually say um
we're kind of going like what the [__]
when uh
when he said he had never heard that Tom
Petty song and like everybody was like
flipping out mostly older people
what do you mean you didn't hear that
big hit that was a hit when I was a kid
this is the thing that you gotta you
gotta know about about these the kids
all right they don't even know who the
[__] Paul McCartney was Paul McCartney
came out sang with Kanye West and like
kids in their 20s they don't know who
Paul McCartney is some of them don't
even know who the [__] Beatles are
and then those kids who know who the
Beatles are they listen to The Beatles
and they go what's the big deal these
guys are overrated because
their [__] songs are 50 years old
at least the early ones
she loves you okay okay yeah
all that [__]
um all that [__] and all right and
they're they're uh
they're and [__] they're and [__] the
[__] that they did right before they
broke up is as old as me 46. you 44 45
46 years old
they don't know who the [__] they are
so if you don't know who the goddamn
beetles are if they come out
you know with Kanye West
okay
and he sings a [__] song with them
they're not gonna know who the [__] he
is he looks like uh he looks like he
should be like a civil war reenactor now
he's actually more Revolutionary War
when I think of Sir Paul McCartney
I [__] hate that [__] I hate how over
in England they they Knight people
how dumb is that then what do you have a
little [__] pretend sword fight
really is Paul McCartney a [__] He's
knighted no what's he gonna do go storm
a castle in a far away land
or is he just going to put on a big
silly necklace and get down on one
[__] knee oh the whole [__]
thing's stupid
um but anyways yeah I I for the life of
me
I didn't notice that that was the same
song and I don't get how that guy gets
sued but lady uh Lady Gaga doesn't with
that Madonna song
which was the exact same [__] Temple
and I guess the same chord progression
and all of that [__] where I would go in
into like
clubs or whatever and just regular
people were singing the Madonna song
along to the Lady Gaga song I didn't
[__] ever think of the Tom Petty song
with the Sam Smith song and what I love
is the second the lawsuit comes around
then everybody all of a sudden
everybody's Phil Spector now everybody
[__] heard it right everybody's got a
gun in some [__] [__] mouth going
admit it admit it it's a Tom Petty song
right isn't that what he did
can you imagine being in a studio with
that [__] weasel who's walking around
with a goddamn gun coked all up or
whatever the hell he is
I just don't understand how people get
into a situation like that like how bad
do you want to make it that you stay in
a studio the first time the guy waves
the gun around it's like hey Phil I'm
going to Burger King do you want
anything
yeah you pull an absentee father thing
he just abandoned the whole thing what's
he gonna do
do you think a guy that [__] crazy
still drives
probably has some old [__] limo you
know
really high roof so he can hold his
[__] wig
um
anyways you listening to the Monday
Morning podcast I hope this thing is
recording
I really hope it is because I can't hear
myself right now I have a bit of a cold
all right I just
Flew Around the World in the last
[__] I still can't believe I just did
that [__] man
um
hey you know what seems like a really
hacky [__] City to go to
is uh Dubai
and that's just from Landing there and
then seeing all their advertising
you know do you remember that what was
that [__] commercial they had where
they fed those dumb [__]
uh
oh you know what I'm trying to get
better with the add here borderline is
my guilty Madonna pleasure and then my
favorite uh
[__] actual song is bad girl because
of Omar Omar Hakeem is that he said his
[__] drumming on that's the [__] uh
and actually uh when they played it live
on Saturday Night Live a long time ago I
remember uh
just watching him playing the drums on
that and thought he was [__] awesome
um but it's a classic Radio hit you know
you listen to it three times in a row
and you're like you know what I don't
think I ever want to hear that song
again and then you got to wait like
three four years and then you listen to
it again like oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
shut it off shut it off
and that's what you know you have a hit
um
so Sam Smith gets [__] sued what
about that new song that Bruno Mars is
singing on cause Uptown Funk gonna give
it to you I mean how many [__] times
is that song been written
don't believe me just watch how many
times has that line been written dope
dude
this is that same song that same song
comes out every summer
[Music]
oh Jesus hey don't believe me just watch
um whatever the [__] he's saying I have
no idea
uh what was I talking about
and I just oh Dubai
that light just seems like uh
if Jersey Shore
was given just an open [__] checkbook
to make a goddamn City that just that's
what it seems like that with a little
bit of uh [__]
uh Kardashian Calabasas vibe to it
like it seems like when people go to
Dubai
they come back and I imagine they would
say [__] like like dude they had a
Lamborghini store next to a Ferrari
store
next to a water slide where you slid in
the champagne
you know all this [__] horseshit and
then outside of the city they got like a
[__] Tent City
of all these [__] basically
modern-day slaves that had to build the
whole [__] thing just by sitting on
the airplane because we connected in
Dubai
um after we left Mumbai that used to be
Bombay
right Bombay is now suing Mumbai just
like Tom Petty suits Sam Smith the same
[__] City
there's too many of the same letters in
Mumbai that was in Bombay right
would that be just the a
H there's no [__] way I'm trying to
do this in my head anyways back to Dubai
so we we connected in Dubai by the way
to then depart fly over Iran
and then over Russia now I'm [__] as
an American I am nervous flying over
Iran but then when I looked at the
stewardesses and they kind of had those
little fancy little headdress things on
them like oh okay wait I think we're all
right I think I'm on the right team here
I think I should be all right
so but they had all these advertisings
advertisings advertisements for Dubai
for all their stupid hotels over there
and that's it just it reminded me of
that commercial a long time ago where
they had like uh
um do you remember it was just some
shitty restaurant
like Olive Garden or it was like uh
Domino's
you know
Domino's is [__] hilarious dude with
their whole ad campaign where they just
admit that their product sucks
you know like you know what you guys you
know you're right I mean we hate it yeah
you're right it tastes like [__]
we couldn't believe how bad it was
either
we agree we're joining it we're joining
it
like like during Civil Rights you can't
stop it so you join it and then you take
control of it
I I had some of that uh pizza and or I
thought it tastes like [__]
ask not let your pizza to jail for yo yo
yo
right they just joined the [__] thing
they come to our side of the fence
we're yelling at them going your pizza
sucks and then they just join our crowd
yeah
look at sucks and then we're yelling at
nobody and the whole thing goes away and
then they come back with their [__]
Pizza it's the exact same goddamn price
the lovely Nia said it the best she goes
why don't you charge more than 5.99 for
a [__] large maybe you could put a
little more into the product
I mean when you really think about it
that should have been their line
when people said that pizza sucks be
okay hey it's 5.99 for a large
all right you broke son of a [__] I'm
just trying to fill that hole in your
belly
okay yeah it sucks but I have a couple
of beers it starts to taste better
doesn't it all right then
who else is going to bring you this much
[__] food for that little of a price
at two o'clock in the [__] morning
huh
nobody
nobody we all know what you do
this is what you do
you or okay you put in an order
right
for one large pizza
okay
provide it and then you pick another
address out of the [__] phone book
and you order [__] three of them but
it's close enough to the other house so
they know that you're coming your house
first you order four largest for that
[__] place then you have one of your
friends hiding the [__] bushes across
the street the Domino's guy pulls up all
right he jumps out of the car he's gonna
leave it unlocked he brings your pizza
up to the car while you're paying for
that pizza your friends go and they
steal the other [__] pies then you
run around the [__] house and you got
four pies for 5.99 okay
that's how it was done
anyways we should just go out and just
grab them and just eat whatever the
other people
[__] ordered and then you know a lot
of times it was something you didn't
want like a vegetable pizza which is so
[__] stupid it's like they have
vegetables or eat something bad okay
stop with you already have the guilt as
you're eating this
all right
it's a cheese topping or salami not
salami pepperoni mushroom something like
that okay enough with the [__]
peppers and all of that [__]
I mean how much heartburning you're
trying to get here so then what we would
do is then eventually we'd start to
order pizzas
you know that we wanted
a little further down the street knowing
that they come to our place first
occasionally it didn't work out and then
they just went to somebody's [__]
house and they're like we didn't order
that [__] oh you're serious yeah serious
and then they come to our house and then
we'd still steal it and that's how you
did it
that was how it was done
um
but it wasn't dominoes what was that I'm
trying to talk about Dubai here that
[__] commercial I think it was Olive
Garden
where they had these people sit down and
they had cloth napkins and they had all
this [__] Pomp and Circumstance right
if that's how you say it
um swamp and circumstantial evidence
right
and then they're eating this pasta and
they're going oh my God it's so decadent
right and what I loved was they had a
bunch of animals eating the [__] so of
course they think it's great the second
you throw a cloth napkin
okay it's somebody that goes to a
tanning bed I mean they automatically
think that they're eating a five-star
[__] meal you've already mind [__]
them
it's like those psychological tests
where they give them a pill that doesn't
do anything but you tell them it's going
to make them feel better and then they
they convince themselves that they feel
better
right
that to me is like what Dubai is Dubai
is like
you know
if you took Olive Garden's pasta
you know however they're trying to make
it you know all the bread you want like
that's that's Dubai that's what it seems
like to me having said that I'll still
[__] go there if I get a gig
you know so I'm just trying to sell the
[__] that I would say if it was more of
a free [__] area because God knows
I'll go there you know
Jesus Christ I'm going to go over there
just to see what I have to wrap Nia in
I'm gonna have a good time in one of
those countries
I'm going to talk all kinds of [__] I'm
going to make Neo walk like five feet
behind me
Nia looked down at the floor when you
walk behind me
oh that's great they got it down over
there huh you just wrap them all up
yeah that's you know what they're
actually doing they're actually
admitting how much smarter women are
than men
the fact that they have to have them on
that level of control
you know what were they doing before
then they must have just been running
[__] and they're just like we can't
[__] you know why don't you put your
foot down I can't help it I wanted a
[__] her right we'll wrap them up
we can't see what they look like then
they can't use their vaginas to to to
mess with my Minds
I just don't understand why you would do
that
it's got to be crazy like when you
[__] I guess you're definitely gonna
marry somebody
that you love because you can't see what
they look like you know because guys
will put up with a lot
if the woman's beautiful the same way a
lady will put up if you got money and
you're making money and you can provide
they're going to put up with way more
[__] than they should you know and it's
true as much as nobody wants to admit it
we all want to sit there and act like
we're that [__] badass
that has a line in the sand that you
won't cross but give me a [__] break
if she's a 10 there's no line
sure you got it down there and she's
stepping over all over it
what are you gonna do you're gonna walk
you want to walk you know you should
walk when you get in your car and you
drive away [__] [__] [__] audio
you know what you can treat me like that
what do you think I am huh
you [__] with the wrong dude dude
right all that [__] you say in your car
you know what happens that fear voice in
the back of your head
what if this is the best looking person
I'm ever with and I and I never find
anybody else I grow a dick
you know you're flipping back and forth
but you're not gonna do it right the
same thing with the broads
they do the same thing okay you walk
around you got yourself an ATM card you
buy them a couple of trinkets down in
the mall and all of a sudden they start
feeling comfortable
right next thing you know you take a
little bit of your frozen yogurt you
flip it right in their face and what do
they do
you know do they leave you no
do they pout sure they do you know but
they're not going anywhere
you just bought them a couple of [__]
t-shirts over at the Hot Topic where the
[__] are they going
huh
sorry that was really negative all right
let's uh let's do a little bit of
advertising here
so many one of those ad companies
figured out that if you say it three
times they're gonna remember it
you know
what should I say here what should I say
three times that'll make you [__] do
it uh
I don't know what I'm thinking
I feel like I got a hype of Joe deroza
date here
for best it's taking a bunch of heat out
there let's see here where's Joe De Rosa
going to be at
Joe DeRosa De Rosa
where is he where is he where is he
Christ he'll come up here in a second my
[__] computer you just love how your
computer is just to [__] for like three
weeks after you buy it yeah it's the
fastest thing out there and then it just
sucks after that
such a [__] rip-off anyways what did
I want to talk about this week
um
American Sports let's talk about that I
have no [__] idea who's doing what
I know the Bruins were playing really
well right up to the all-star break and
then we uh I don't know we've been
having a day we've been having a rough
one you know
um I think we lost a van it's the
beginning of a big West Coast uh
trip here and I got I got to get back
into uh
watching that type of stuff
um
I do have to tell you our [__] sports
are awesome over here
you know we have
at least three really exciting sports
football
hockey basketball a [__] exciting
goddamn Sports
all right they have basketball over in
Australia but it's called netball and
women play it and there's no backboard I
can watch that a little bit
but the rules are I can't remember if
they can't dribble or some [__] it's
like they get it then they just have to
stop
I don't see any dunking or any of that
type of stuff but um
I'm looking forward
to getting back into it but um I have no
idea what's going on one of my buddies
up in Canada gave me [__] because I
guess we got swept by the Canadians
um for the season
it's so sad to listen to the Canadian
fans gloat about that
season sweep is complete you know yeah
yeah there's your Stanley Cup what are
you guys done in the last 20 years lose
the Expos
[Laughter]
after we lost them much
much all right in a real League Montreal
not that poor [__] CFL thing you have up
there
all right where Bobby brister can go up
there and [__] throw for 500 yards or
meters whatever the [__] you call them
up there
every goddamn game
[__] break
did I already did I already break New
York City's balls
do you realize that the [__] city of
Boston with four teams has won one more
Championship than the than the [__]
city of New York has professional teams
we have enough rings to give each
[__] sad ass New York [__] team a
[__] ring and still have one left
over for ourselves with just four tapes
that's why I don't respect New York
Sports in their championships it's like
you doubled down in every [__] sport
gee did you win one how many at bats do
you need two baseball two football two
basketball and if you include the
Islanders they got two [__] hockey
it's [__] pathetic
oh no I love rubbing it into those [__]
and you're probably going like Bill why
are you rubbing it in on lip that's
because they've been dicks to me my
entire [__] Sports life because we
now we never want anything
and they and all of them [__] just
run and hide anytime Boston wins
something or they try to oh no I'm happy
for you last year I'm really happy for
you guys go [__] yourselves
go [__] yourselves all right
I swear to God it's what that city is is
it's the Yankees
the Yankees propped that entire [__]
City up if if it wasn't for the [__]
Yankees New York City would be exposed
as being basically one of the saddest
places to to ever be as a sports fan
you know
wait the Giants are good why don't we
talk about the Giants are good but
rather than that all right the Jets
horrific 1969. the Knicks you know you
have to get it it's 1973.
the Rangers have won one cup in like
[__] 90 years 80 years right
look at this Nets have never won
anything
the Islanders
they had their run but at that point
it's like 30 [__] years
ago
they're playing better though right
I know just a sad
sad [__] you got the Yankees thank God
for the [__] Yankees have won like 99
I guess they probably won 99 for
everybody but
I don't know I don't know I'm gloating
here a little bit
a hell of a [__] decade everybody and
if you think I think that this is going
to last I know it isn't I know that
right now I am at the tail end of the
greatest run Boston Sports is going to
have in my lifetime
I know I don't know when it's gonna end
but uh
I'll take it
if it just becomes like you know like
the Bruins don't seem like they have it
this year it seems like they're gonna
have to [__] shake it up uh Celtics
it goes without saying
um Red Sox you never know but today's
game we kind of seem like we uh win it
then we [__] the bed
then we win it so we'll see what happens
maybe we'll uh
we'll come back around try to stay uh
we'll try to keep up with the Giants
we've won three they've won three in
this century
well we'll be like one ahead if we end
up winning it this year who the who the
[__] knows and the Patriots I don't know
what happens with them but at some point
Belichick's gonna have to retire and
Brady's gonna have to retire and then
we're gonna go back to being the team
that I watched when I was growing up and
uh
you watch how that Stadium empties out
[Laughter]
it's gonna go right but you know what
would be funny is if you actually had a
camera right
like doing like this
still photography and you had people who
were there
um basically before Bob Craft and you
got them in their seats and then you
just sort of fast forward through all
the years
Robert Kraft Bill Parcells Pete Carroll
bill belichicki you see the stadium
filling up filling up filling up and
then they gradually retire and then all
the seats around start getting empty
again and then you just see that same
person you saw
before Robert Kraft bought the team and
he's just [__] much older [__] am I
gonna sneeze here God damn it I hope I
didn't catch a [__] cold
um
so anyways
somebody was telling me that they read a
story that Pete Carroll said that
I don't know if it was like three nights
in a row whatever but he was laying in
bed crying
that he lost the Super Bowl and
that's why I love Pete Carroll
I can't I mean I hate that and I hate
the Dockers but that [__] guy
is so [__] driven
he wants to Win It Do You Realize like
the pain
that guy that guy was going to do
something that I'm trying to think how
many people did it
if he went back-to-back Super Bowls that
guy joins Vince Lombardi Don Shula Chuck
Knoll
uh Jimmy Johnson
and Bill Belichick
that's it right
he would become one of six people
to ever do it and he'd be in the same
the same [__] category as Lombardi
Schuler Chuck Knoll
Jimmy Johnson and Bill Belichick Bill
Belichick by the way I would actually
say is the greatest coach of all [__]
time
of all [__] time how long he's won
doing it now in the salary cap era the
amount of [__] players
switching in switching out even when he
doesn't win it we still win like 12 13
[__] games a year
um
I think he's I think he's the greatest
of all time and I really hope that we
keep pushing to get the [__] Colts to
make some sort of public apology for
their absolute [__]
they're such [__] babies man I love
Andrew Luck this is nothing against the
Colts the team it's their [__] owner
man that guy is such a goddamn baby
the amount of times that they've lost
and then you know of course they can't
just lose it has to be like a [__]
rule change he's got to send a video to
the to the league office it's like dude
you're lost
go [__] yourself
what a [__] baby man
anyways
so but you know they threw it out there
it was great they threw it out there so
forever Bill Belichick you know by all
the [__] people out there who just
hate the guy are forever gonna quit I
love how Jerry Rice sits there and goes
yeah you know they should have an
asterisk next to their uh their
championship and then admits to use and
stick them
give me a [__] break so now what
Jerry now you're not now you're no
longer the greatest receiver of all time
give me a [__] break you still are
grow up
um
so anyways I was on the uh I was on the
plane coming back from uh Dubai and um
I blew I blew basically all any any gig
money that I made going through Asia I
blew on plane tickets because I'm too
[__] old to fly in the back of the
plane I just can't do it okay I can't
I'm too [__] old so I actually lost
money
going through Asia
and probably lost a good month of my
life breathing in some of that air over
there
uh but I'm still going back because I
absolutely loved it and I [__] love
the people over there so
uh Nia was giving me [__]
because she saw the money that I spent
she saw what I was gonna gross and then
what I spent on plane tickets she's like
what the [__] are you doing and I was
just like listen you can't put a price
on it okay
this is like a [__] vacation just
look at it that way and we're actually
gonna maybe make a little money on this
thing
all right but I am not gonna [__]
fly to Australia with my [__] pasty
knees up to my chest I'm not doing it
all right
so enjoy it so like the entire time we
just flew business class all right
and uh
every time we go on and get a nice seat
and I just kept looking over at Nia just
going you can't put a price on it
you know you can't put I just kept
saying that
and she just kept shaking her head and
you'd get off the plane and then they'd
give you a little pass so when you went
through customs just letting you guys
know this so if you want to use your
[__] miles I'm telling you look if
you're flying within the United States I
mean you don't need to do that I guess
New York to LA is a [__] but you
can handle that but when you start
talking about a 14 10 14 hour [__]
flight take out your miles take out your
credit card just I'm telling you
I'm telling you
you won't regret it so we're flying back
air Emirates and it was one of those
double decker planes
and we were upstairs in the business
class so we're like [__] ridiculously
excited totally exposing ourselves
um
and so I got went up to get to the you
know we sit down
and uh
you know nice big ass [__] chairs
and I look and I look over at Nia and
she laughs and goes you can't put a
price on it I'm like that's right so uh
I get up like about an hour into the
flight and I go in the bath to go to the
bathroom I go in the back and they have
a they have a bar
in the back of the plane
like not giant bar but just like a
little [__]
but a bartender sitting there with a
bunch of [__] booze behind you know
bottles and all that [__] and then on
either side of the plane like they got
these s-shaped benches with like four
seats with four seat belts and you can
just sit down put on the seat belt
like you're at a bar
so I like my [__] heart I can't
believe I didn't faint my heart weight
went through the [__] seal so I go
back
and I go nia nia come on to the back of
the plane
she's like what what you know she's
watching some [__] TV thing and I go
like come on I want to get you a drink
she goes what am I get me a drink she
thinks I'm just gonna go back there's
gonna be like three stewardesses like
huddled in the back we go in the back
and she saw it she just starts laughing
we sat down put seat belts on it ordered
the [__] drinks they had like olives
and [__] back there was ridiculous
and I looked at her and she finally said
it she goes you can't put a price on it
it was one of the great [__] moments
and I sat with her drinking a goddamn
drink flying over Iraq
God if I'm gonna get hit by a [__]
RPG I'm gonna be doing it like this this
is the way to do it
right so uh that is the one thing that
I've learned through all of my [__]
travel is that uh
you have to have a line
and once you you're going Beyond
I mean granted I haven't gotten the bill
yet
when I get that bill oh Jesus when I get
that bill
um
I don't know I don't give a [__] [__]
that I don't give a [__] all right I
need to be comfortable if I'm going into
a goddamn country where I could get
caned or hung you know
you want to ride there in a comfy chair
so
um
all right well I'm already 40 minutes in
here I gotta I gotta [__] move along
here but um I can't even remember what I
talked about
last week as far as India um
it was such a good time maybe I'll tell
the story again if I've already told it
but after after the gig in India
um
I hung out with a bunch of comics all
went out and got dinner and just sat
down and taught comedy for uh
for like a good hour and it was probably
one of the highlights of my career
just as far as just one of the coolest
things ever you're on the other side of
the globe
hanging out
and you met people that do what you do
that have the same passion and love for
it and what was killing me was the
questions were the exact same questions
that I would hear from American Comics
or Comics I met in the UK or Ireland or
Scandinavia it's just it's because it's
the same art form
and um
my favorite thing was in the end when it
started getting Petty where they were
going like all right Bill who's a comic
that you think just [__] stinks but
for on some unexplained reason is
selling a bunch of tickets
I just started laughing I was just like
Jesus even over here it's like that you
know but uh
I don't know that's one of the really
cool things about uh
about traveling or whatever so
um
I'm definitely gonna go back definitely
gonna go back and what's funny is
um Jerry Seinfeld actually has
is doing four shows over there
um
and uh I was just back in New York
next month he's going to be over there
and I was just in New York was doing the
Patrice O'Neill benefit
and uh I just happened to run into
Seinfeld he comes down to cell you know
which is always [__] unreal when he
shows up
and I mentioned to him that he was you
know
him going over there so it's just kind
of comparing trading notes with them or
whatever so I can't wait to hear how
those shows go
because he was you know he's asking all
the questions like you know can they
understand like yes I was like dude they
get everything they get everything all
the slang and all that [__] but uh
anyways I that
I don't know I I wish I could actually
go to those shows that'd be pretty cool
I'll see in Seinfeld and [__] Mumbai
um
anyways uh so Patricia O'Neill benefit
ladies and gentlemen uh thank you to
everybody that came out
to the uh to the benefit this year I
actually think was one of the best shows
because
um we only had eight Comics this year in
the past the thing is so many people
love Patrice and so many people wanna
be a part of it that we've been having
like 12 to 13 comics and it really gets
like jammed up towards the end and it's
a union house and if we go over like you
know unions that finds it through the
roof and we're defeating the purpose
of why we're doing this thing so it
becomes really stressful this year there
was only eight moved along quick and um
you know everybody crushed it and uh
this year was great because I felt like
by having Hannibal Burris and Michael
Che on it we actually had guys that were
influenced by patrice's comedy
um this is the first time we didn't just
have like his peers the guys he came up
with
that started at the same time he did or
maybe a little bit before this is when
we actually had the generation of comics
set as they were deciding to become
comedians could actually have watched
Patrice on TV and been influenced by him
and uh
those two guys killed it uh Jim
Florentine Ben Bailey David tell Jim
Norton Colin Quinn
uh Rich Voss hosting it as always
um
it was just an awesome awesome time I
know I always forget somebody and
they're going to get [__] pissed at
me but um
I don't know thanks again to everybody
who uh came out to that thing we're
gonna of course do it again
next year thank you to the Opie and
Jimmy show for helping me promote it
blah blah blah blah and all that type of
stuff and um
I don't know it's definitely uh it's
I know it's one it's my favorite thing
to do of the year because uh it is such
a great cause we obviously love Patrice
and getting to see his mom his
stepdaughter and his uh his girlfriend
and uh
becomes like a like this stand-up like
high school reunion man it's really
[__] cool so
all right here we go I gotta wrap this
up because guess what I'm doing the
second this podcast is over other than
uploading it is I get to go see my dog I
haven't seen my dog in like three weeks
I know what you're thinking like Bill
where did you put your dog where did you
board your dog and it's like no I just
kept her in the garage you know [__] and
pissed all over the place but I had
plenty of food for her
and you know I had to tied to a pole
um
we actually border at our our
veterinarian and my dog is one of the
few dogs that absolutely loves the vet
because she you know she's a pit bull
she's got herself hurt a couple of times
because she's a maniac and um
you know
my dog's got this thing that he looks at
you she looks at you sideways like who
the [__] are you the second you take
care of her that's it
you're you're a made man
so they took care of her a couple of
times you know
she broke one of her
teeth one time and uh a couple other
things she's done to herself banged
herself up and
um you know they took care of her down
there once she sees that someone's gonna
take care of she's like she's like a
little [__]
God damn baby when she's down there so
whenever I take her to the vet all these
other dogs are like whining going in
there and I'm like water skiing behind
my dog she's like dragging me in there
what kills me is whenever I drop her off
to border she's so excited to be there
she doesn't even turn around and look at
me
your Tails wagging and she just [__]
runs away with somebody else kind of
hurts my feelings a little bit but um
anyways let's get to the uh
let's get to the uh the the [__] um
what am I saying here the the letters
for this week all right Sam Smith and
Tom Petty I actually kind of already
answered this one uh
what is this one
all right I've been a big fan of the
podcast for years I gotta say hello and
correct congrats to you and lovely Nia
when you played Dublin Ireland a while
back
oh I got to say congrats you okay this
is a trivial point but I'd like to throw
in my two cents on Tom Petty's suing Sam
Smith Tom Petty is Almost Famous for
looking the other way when people happen
to sound like him he's been quoted as
Laughing it off when last night by The
Strokes appeared to rip off American
girl saying his early stuff and then he
just said that his early stuff sounded
like Chuck Berry he even gave The
Strokes credit for owning up to it
there's a similar story about The Red
Hot Chili Peppers Danny California
sounding like Last Dance With Mary Jane
however in this case with Sam Smith
Smith's response to the story was that
he never heard I Won't Back Down if we
believe that are we supposed to believe
that every musician producer another
[__] heard that song before it was
released had never heard Tom Petty's I
Won't Back Down
uh maybe so
for what my dumbass opinion is worth
Petty either sued because he didn't
believe the denial or he was offended
because Sam Smith didn't know him and
not because the song sounded alike but
what the hell do I know that's actually
interesting come back to Ireland
sometime soon thanks and go [__]
yourself that's a really interesting
take I never even thought about that if
he just owned up to it like giving it
pulled over by a cop and you just you
know you know why I pulled you over yep
yep I made that illegal U-turn why'd you
make it because I was impatient and I
didn't want to do it the right way
do you know I could give you a ticket
yeah yeah I do but I'm not gonna lie to
you
that's an actual conversation I have
with a cop
and then he goes all right I'm going to
let you go and then I laughed and said
you're awesome and then he laughed like
not laughing like yeah this is great he
was laughing just like it was just a
weird conversation for him I think
I always tell the truth whenever they
pull you up you know I pulled you over
yeah absolutely I was doing like [__]
you know fashion going yeah like 85.
I was hoping I wasn't going to run into
you
most of the times they still give you
the ticket but sometimes if you're just
[__] honest
you know it's towards the end of this
shift they'll actually [__] let you
go
um
yeah of course being a [__] freckled
face
howdy Duty looking white guy probably
doesn't hurt me either I'm already
hearing anybody not white listening to
this going oh yeah yeah
I know I know what do you want me to do
you know
it's one of my I mean I I don't make the
rules I'm happy it works out that way
for me I'm sorry it doesn't for you
uh moving across the country
uh dear Bill birth bill I think your
podcast thank you okay okay I just I I
just turned 23 years old a few months
ago and I realized I have lived in the
in the West Michigan town I've
officially lived in the western Michigan
town I live in for more than half my
life can you guys please
please try to proofread your [__] this
is his sentence okay so I turned 23 a
few months ago and I realized I have
lived in the West Michigan town I've
officially lived in the western Michigan
town I live in for more than half my
life
all right so it's definitely editing as
he wrote this and just kind of [__]
that up this crushed me
right because you're living in western
Michigan I like it out there
wait you're gonna move to the big city
uh this crushed me so I began saving up
as I wanted to live in Portland Oregon
good choice
I've always been Musical and I want to
go
do the band thing but I have never but I
have an associates of science degree so
if that doesn't work out I can go back
to school but in Portland after
establishing Reds but I'll go back to
school in Portland after establishing
residency all right so you got a plan
here my question to you is this how much
do you think I should save up with the
plan to live minimally and just work a
job slash play music I've never felt I
could express myself here as I am
isolated and since the town is small
High School follows you everywhere in
which I was a total weirdo slash loser
uh thanks
and go love yourself
um all right
I totally relate I totally relate like
you know I was a loser too in high
school so there was that element of like
going to Boston to try stand-up comedy
and I remember
whenever I would get a gig anywhere near
where I was from
I'd be so nervous that my entire High
School class would show up and they
wouldn't laugh and be like dude you're
that jackass who went to school with
who are you to think that you could make
this dream come true go [__] yourself
right so I totally understand all of
that
and I also worked a day job and I saved
up money before I moved to New York I
paid off all of my debts I just paid it
down I paid down everything and I saved
up uh
I saved up some money and then I moved
to New York
and I went there thinking I got to get a
day job
and but I had enough money where that
wasn't
you know
it wasn't dire like I got to get a job
right now I could actually go a few
months so I started getting some
stand-up gigs
so even though it was negative cash flow
it wasn't 100 negative like say my nut I
think my rent I swear to God I had a
walk-through bedroom my rent was uh
it was 4.25 a month
this is 20 years ago
and um
but I mean I had no spots I had no gigs
so I think I did a couple of Road gigs
went probably back to Boston maybe did a
dick Doherty gig or something and I
probably made
Jesus I don't even know I probably made
like 300 bucks 375 for the weekend but I
also had to travel up there and I took
the bus and I had to eat so I was
probably unpaid taxes on it eventually
so I mean I was probably walking away
with 125 bucks
so I probably had you know and plus all
the other eating living every time you
walked outside New York it's like you
blew 20 bucks
so
um I watched my nest egg start to
dwindle
but
after a couple months I stopped thinking
about a day job I just started thinking
um
I got to get more gigs and I got to get
more gigs and then what happened was
I was able to kind of slowly stop the
nosedive of cash to level it off a
little bit
and um
then I I booked some acting gig or
something where I was able to make
enough money and I just stashed it
and at that point then I got a college
agent it just all starts to happen you
know what
um a guy I brought up on this
um
podcast before Mike Johnston
mikelestens.com I'll try to find a video
for you but
he's got this great video that he does
where he talks about
you know or maybe I was when I went and
I saw him live I think it was when I saw
him live so I'll paraphrase what he said
but when he wanted to make money as a
musician
you know
he just
he just totally like his day even his
day job he just stayed in the Music
Arena I'm really going to butcher this
story but he started giving drum lessons
all right so that was money he was
earning as a drummer he started working
at a music studio tuning up the drums
and that type of thing
so that was two-way and then then he got
into you know a couple of bands and he
had a couple gigs on the weekend so that
was
three four different ways that he was
making money as a drummer he just keep
doing that so when you're out there I
would just make make it all about music
you know if you get a job at [__]
Guitar Center or something like that you
can get a discount on some of your your
equipment and then you can also get to
know guys and he can start talking to
people like I want to get into a band
join a couple of [__] bands I mean
that's
I would do all of that [__] and then
also you can get a discount and all the
recording stuff that you need if you're
going to start writing songs I would
just keep getting jobs
in the music uh industry because it
seems to me like that's what you want to
do and then your backup is to do this
Associates
of the Sciences degree
like that's your backup plan
um
just by reading your letter it seems
like you know you want to be in the
music business that's going to make you
happy so that's what I would do and uh
you just kind of have to try to shake
off that whole idea that
you know you have to fall back on this
college degree and this whole idea that
you can't have a fun job you can totally
have a fun job and it's going to be a
job and it's going to be working all
that [__] but you can totally have a fun
job
um
you just keep applying for jobs that are
fun and you will have a fun job and just
stay there and then that's it and then
you know you know how to do it dude your
ramen noodles
dude if you wake up in the morning you
just have a [__] Apple that'll fill
you up
and you'll be in great shape you just
pound some Waters
um
you know you know the deal everybody
[__] does this [__]
I used to eat spaghetti that was my
thing spaghetti and
and a couple pieces of bread and that
was my dinner that would fill me up
and uh I remember I didn't have I didn't
have a table I had a [__] chair that
I turn around and I use that as the
table and I just would [__]
get the Prego and I throw [__]
spaghetti in there I could make the
[__] meal in my sleep I didn't have
to measure the water or anything I just
knew where to pour it in the pot I just
had it every [__] night
and I was so [__] sick of it I
remember like every once in a while I
would either take a taxi cab I'd just be
so tired after doing gigs and just
[__] every once in a while I treat
myself to a cab ride or I treat myself
I'd actually order out
and when I say all around I'm talking
like ordering Chinese food
um
because you know when you first moved to
a city you know from a small town you
moved to a big city you're on your own
and it's really on you
uh uh you're terrified to spend money
this is creeping thing you know you got
to get your footing once you know you've
survived
for seven eight months one day it just
kind of hits you like hey I'm on my own
here and I'm I'm making it it's a great
feeling
you know even though you got [__]
spaghetti coming out of your goddamn
ears
um so good luck to you sir all right so
uh
work out a William B do you still work
out if yes what is your routine do you
do any running or biking love the
podcast man uh I actually did quite a
bit of working out when I was on on the
road because I was you know eating
airplane food airport food and that type
of stuff and gig food uh
and I only think I put on like five
pounds which is pretty good
you know for the amount of time I was
away for three weeks to only put on five
pounds
and really what [__] me over was when
I went to New York I was there for a few
days and uh
oh the booze was flowing anyways
um
do I do any running no I don't do
running run kills my [__] you know you
can't do that t stuff at my age
you can't keep running like that it
[__] you need your feet your knees
your hips you need all of that [__] for
the rest of your life what you really
have to do at my age is actually finally
sit down and learn about nutrition
so you're not eating your way into the
gym you're actually eating your way out
of it so you don't have to do as much I
do a lot like I take my dog
um there's a lot of hiking trails out
here in L.A
the [__] greatest City ever I love it
man have to be in that freezing [__]
New York I love New York and that [__]
but uh
Jesus Christ when it's that [__] cold
and there's no Christmas lights out it's
pretty goddamn bleak
um
but anyways yeah I kind of do that and
then I'm into uh
your own body weight I have a climbing
rope I got a pegboard I got uh
I got one of those pull-up dip stations
I'm into that type of stuff because I
feel like
it's a much better strength
being able to move your own body and
it's much more practical when you're in
situations to be able to move your body
um climb up onto something lower
yourself down onto something just
getting it up and out of bed is easier
if you're used to
being able to handle your own body
weight as opposed to that weird [__]
with like bench pressing which is you're
pushing all this weight up off of you
while adding this muscle weight to
yourself which is I don't know
it just seems more of a complete workout
when you're moving your own body so I'm
into that stuff and uh I'll skip rope I
guess every once in a while but I make
sure that I do like I don't jump up too
high
so it's more like I'm kind of not even
like running in place it's almost just
sort of lifting a foot up and setting it
back down uh once you get the muscle
memory down you can really
minimally be slamming your joints as
you're coming back down
uh it's sort of like lightly running in
place as you do it
and I'll just do like two three rounds
you know what's funny is I brought it I
brought a jump rope on the trip and I
never used it once
I just never [__] used it but I did
do like a lot of that elliptical [__]
and um
I don't know
so what I what's my routine all right
it's my routine I do
a set of Pull-Ups
and I do it to exhaustion as many as I
can do and even after I can't put my
head over the chin I get my chin over
the over the bar I still are am doing
reps
even if you only go halfway up a third
of the way up an eighth of the way up
and just to exhaustion that's the first
set I do
then uh I climb up the Rope go back down
and then I go over to the pegboard
and it's weird because my garage ceiling
isn't high enough I had to buy the
skinniest ones and to have them go
horizontal so I'm actually
I only do the pegboard but I go to the
side and at this point I'm only at the
point where
you know I can take the pegs out like
two or three times
total
um
you know and actually make it happen if
you do get a pegboard you want to aim a
little bit higher than the whole because
your your body's going to be going down
so you actually stick it in there
and then the next time I go through is I
do a set of pull-ups where I do the
negatives will you pull yourself up over
the bar and then you lower yourself
super slow
and that actually helps your reps over
time and then the next and then I do the
I got this tree that I jump up and I
there's a branch that goes way out where
I kind of do a
how the [__] do you describe it right
hand over left hand right hand over left
hand walking out towards the end of the
branch and then I come all the way back
again
and I try to keep my arms at like a 90
degree angle not just hanging straight
down like that
um
and then the third set I do is a wide
grip and it's the same thing again and I
go back up the Rope instead of the tree
that time something like that and then
I'm always switching it up
um sometimes I just do three straight
things of regular pull-ups or whatever
this sounds boring as [__] so I'm gonna
move on but that's basically what I do
and then I take my dog for a [__]
hike
that's it and then I try not to eat like
a [__] animal
there you go and that is my workout let
me actually do the last bit of
advertising here
[__] uh Richard Simmons what the hell
am I doing here I'm sitting in candy
stripe shorts right now people doing
this podcast all right out of the closet
here we go dear Bill I'm a 17 year old
high school student who recently came
out of the closet congratulations that's
a very courageous thing it's 17.
um I have always been fairly timid and
don't have a very aggressive character
once again even more courageous three
years ago I found your comedy and I was
inspired by your your religion of logic
and passion listening to your comedy
an hour on the podcast gave me exposure
to a strong personality that I could
relate to internally and be inspired by
outwardly like if this is going to be
all compliments I can't read these all
right some point you got a [__] on me uh
without exaggeration exaggeration it
moved my time table up at least a year
for forever I plan on waiting till I was
18. thank you for the inspiration good
sir uh this is where you call yourself
an idiot and downplay the situation ah
you son of a [__] you were two
sentences short
I lifted that move from you too when my
aunt said I was very brave I just
brushed it off like you will with this
email go [__] yourself Jesus Christ
this [__] guy's killing it here
um should I be worried
oh it's totally different this is a
different thing I actually just assumed
that this was a guy too
it could have been a lady
all right should I be worried well
congratulations sir or ma'am
um where am I uh should I be worried hey
Bill Burrington
the first
please read this on them
so I'm an English guy studying
psychology in France
and I've been dating an Italian girl for
the last five months dude what are you
[__] James Bond
I'm insanely in love this International
[__] what is the problem should I be
worried you should be worried you're an
English guy living in France studying
psychology dating some Italian woman
[__] awesome I want your life
uh he goes I'm insanely in love with her
and I think she may be the one or at
least the mother of my hypothetical
children hilarious we both have a long
history of relationship I've been with a
lot of girls and she's been with a lot
of guys nice you both experienced you
came out of it unscathed no STDs that's
that's great for both of you
you know what that's like when you've
banged a lot of women and she's banged a
lot of guys and you get there unscathed
you know what that's like that's like
one of those great [__] Super Bowl
matchups you know that's a pickle
it's like the Cowboys Steelers 79. uh
I'm insanely in love with her but wait
okay the other day I bought I brought up
an X and this obviously pissed her off
yeah what the [__] you don't do that
because she then said she was speaking
with an ex on Facebook and and he said
he wanted to marry her I know she's
still friends with some of her exes
though so am I
but I still you guys both need to
[__] grow up all right either get out
of this relationship
friends with your exes
but I still think her getting messages
from these guys who clearly still want
to [__] her is messed up obviously and
why you still talking to your ladies
uh you're keeping them in your little
[__] dick orbit aren't you
uh we're moving in together at the end
of the year and usually you would say
dump the [__] no I'm not I'm saying you
both need to grow up but she says she
loves me and I can't lose this one she's
[__] beautiful smart funny and sweet
so should I be worried about these
[__] and therefore bring it up or
should I just shrug it off thanks and go
[__] yourself what I think you need to
do is you need to commit to this woman
you have to tell us say listen I'm not
talking to any my any more of my exes
and I would appreciate it if you would
do the same
I think we got a great thing going here
and um
you know
I don't I don't feel it's right that I'm
still in contact with women that I used
to be intimate with
it doesn't feel right to me anymore the
way I feel about you
and I'm hoping
that you feel the same way about you
keeping in contact with your exes I'm
not trying to have a fight here I just
want to have a rational conversation
just start that way and then you know
what you commit to our dude and it's
over okay all those other [__] guys
that banged her and all that type of
stuff did they give her a ring no
you know so you sound like you're an
older guy as far as like you've been
down the [__] you know
you know you've been hacking your way
through the jungle for a while who the
[__] kid and who all right
what are you gonna do here you know
you're gonna lose this one
I don't think you're gonna
so commit to her and then just show you
come in like but you know once you lead
by example
maybe that'll work I don't [__] know
but uh that whole [__] will you both
stay in uh
well you're both [__] um
you know staying in contact with your
exes is [__]
uh come on who's kid no and you know if
you're a little drunk and then you get
on the [__] Facebook there [__] is
said so
you know what you need to do you both do
all right good luck to you all right
that's the podcast for this week go [__]
yourself oh there's Joe DeRosa Joe to
Rosa will be at the punch line in San
Francisco
this weekend
all Twinkle Toes himself so if you're in
the San Francisco area go see [__]
Joe to Rosa all right there you go
that's my two cents for the [__] week
uh I'm gonna get caught up on some
Bruins games I'm psyched to be back and
once again thank you
thank you to everybody Australia New
Zealand New Zealand Singapore Hong Kong
and Mumbai uh thanks for coming out to
the shows